sie haben es wahrscheinlich schon
mitbekommen über die nachrichten Ticker
Russland greift seit diesem Morgen mit
Raketen wieder verstärkt Ziele in der
Ukraine an auch im Zentrum der
Hauptstadt Kiew gab es schwere
Explosionen Präsident selensky hat
bereits tote und verletzt bestätigt nach
der Explosion auf der krimbrücke jetzt
am Wochenende hatte der Krimi ja mit
Vergeltung gedroht und dazu sprechen wir
jetzt
telefonisch mit zdf-reporterin Alisa
jung die sich gerade in einem Bunker
mitten im Kiew befindet deshalb eben
auch keine videoleitung sondern nur ein
Telefon Alissa wie ist denn die Lage vor
Ort was kannst Du dazu sagen und wie
geht es euch
genau das ist angesprochen wir sind zum
zweiten Mal für heute jetzt unten im
Bunker denn wir wurden eigentlich fast
geweckt kann man sagen um kurz nach 8
Uhr unserer Zeit das ist dann 7 Uhr
deutsche Zeit morgens von eben heftigen
Explosionen ganz in der Nähe von uns
auch das ist nämlich muss man sich so
vorstellen mitten im Zentrum von Kiel
und sind dann also in den Bunker und
jetzt zum zweiten Mal dort denn die
Explosionen das hat nicht aufgehörte
Angriff aus Kiel das sind gab inzwischen
mehrere Angriffe und was man dazu sagen
muss ist dass es natürlich hier mitten
im Berufsverkehr am Montag morgen
getroffen hat bei schönsten Sonnenschein
und das sind eben auch viele getroffen
worden ganz normal aus dem Leben also
ein Tag online von uns ein
Kinderspielplatz der in diesem Park auch
war dann und hat von einer Uni eben gab
es die Explosion also von der Uni hier
in Kiew also mitten im Berufsverkehr hat
dass die Stadt jetzt getroffen am
Montagmorgen und natürlich jetzt schwer
beunruhigend für alle Menschen die hier
leben was da jetzt noch weiter auf uns
zukommt den heutigen Tag über was ist
denn was ist ein paar Beispiele genannt
über das das Ausmaß dieser Angriffe
bekannt also auch zahlenmäßig weiß man
wie viele Raketen eingeschlagen haben
wie viel Explosionen es gab
heute morgen war die Rede von hier
Explosionen aber diese Zahl ist jetzt
wahrscheinlich auch gerade noch weiter
am steigen dann gab es mehrere Verletzte
und auch einige Tote bestätigt von der
Kiel war Polizei allerdings sind es ich
meine nur fünf fünf Tote 12 letzte bei
den Angriffen wir haben aber auch schon
höhere Zahlen gehört also in dem Fall es
gab auch Opfer bei den Angriffen und
nicht nur in Kiew sondern im ganzen Land
wurden Städte angegriffen und das ist
schon auch ein Zeichen dafür dass das
jetzt hier natürlich das ganze dann
irgendwie betrifft betrifft und es wurde
ja im Vorfeld auch tatsächlich
angekündigt von Russland die sich also
für diesen Angriff auf die krimbrücke
von Samstag lassen sich dafür rächen
wollen ein Terroranschlag nannte dass
der russische Präsident und so ist der
Montag hier jetzt in der Ukraine mit
Angriffen auf mehrere Städte
diese Woche jetzt gestartet okay das
heißt man hat damit gerechnet dass das
kommt nur man hat nicht an diesem Morgen
damit gerechnet
entweder jetzt hier in der Hauptstadt
die haben jetzt monatelang tatsächlich
nicht betroffen war und jetzt hier der
ganze Bereich auch quasi im Norden der
jenseits der Frontlinie ist der da war
ist es ja tatsächlich auch in den
letzten Wochen Monaten ruhiger geworden
also es gab jetzt wieder Angriffe eben
jenseits der Fronten im Süden und Osten
und damit wurde jetzt vielleicht in
diesem Ausmaßen nicht unbedingt
gerechnet
Dankeschön für die Einschätzung direkt
aus Kiew Alissa jung passt bitte bei
euch auf Euch auf danke schön
ciao